بدايه من 2023 كم واحد قرا كتاب
زين ثلاث كتب
كم واحد هالاسبوع سمع بودكاست
قاعه كلها
انا ماجد العدواني
اشتغل
بانك واعلام وميديا واذاعه
كل هذا على جنب اليوم انا جاي اكلمكم
عن فرصه وعن واقع وعن فرص احنا ما نشوفها
اصلا
مو سر ان الحضاره الانسانيه
الثوره الاولى ثوره زراعيه انسان بلش يزرع
يبي ياكل
استمرت هي الثوره الاطول بعدين الثوره
الصناعيه بلش الانسان يصنع يبدع يتالق
وبعدين الثوره اللي احنا عايشينها اليوم
ثوره المعلوماتيه او ما يسمى بثوره
المعلومه صراحه
لان جماعه يقولون دشينا بالرابعه بس انا
بوقف هنا
الثوره الثالثه
قائمه على المعلومه
مصدرها
تنقلها سرعتها وان توصل شلون نحللها وشلون
نستفيد منها
وتاريخيا
المصادر كانت تختلف
بس في اتفاق على ان المصدر الاساسي هو
الكتاب ان الناس لازم تقرا
وتنقل المعلومات وتناقشها وتحللها
احنا للاسف كان عندنا ضعف اتكلم كمنطقه
كريج كوطن عربي
وايد سمعنا احصائيات ربع صفحه بالسنه
الانسان العربي يقرا ست صفحات كل ما ادري
ايش كثر وعانينا فتره كبيره وفي مشاكل وفي
قضايا ما زالت معلقه للاسف ولا قادرين
نحلها بسبب انه ما نقرا
نقعد قاعد يعني
واقفين بمكاننا ما نتحرك
بس عندنا شيء بالتاريخ احنا مو شايفينه
يعني ولا منتبهين ولا كانه موجود احنا
تاريخنا مليء بالكلام سولف قصص حكايات
اشعار بطولات
واستمروا ويانا هالشي مئات السنين بس
نسولف
نقول قصص
نقول حكايات حتى ان العرب قبل الفين سنه
اثمن كلام عندهم كانت معلقات هو اقوى
انتاج لغوي قاموا لقوها الكعبه هذا اقوى
شيء عندنا
زين هل معلقات
وحتى التاريخ
ممكن نستفيد منه
راح نستفيد منه اذا كملنا
تعرفون قصه
التاجر الاشاره قماش اسود وما انباع
سامعين فيها
هنا في ناس سامعه
واحد شرق ماشي بيبيع قماشه اسود يا جماعه
مسكين ولا عنده بوتيك سمعي يبيع فيه راح
حق واحد شاعر من جماعه الكلام قال انت
جماعه الكلام تسولفون زين
قطع القماش اللي فيها راح قال احنا شطار
بالكلام مسوي لك اياها قل للمليحه بالخمار
الاسود ماذا فعلت بناسك متعبده كذب وملحها
وضبطها انباع كله
ومشي الحال
ليش قوه الكلمه تاثير الكلمه في الثقافه
العربيه تاثير كبير احنا مو حاسين فيه
كذلك العرب لما كانوا يبون يضربون مثال
يبون يدبون واحد
يبون يقولون له ايش كثر مهم الصديق ما
يقولون الصديق مهم واحرص على رفيقك خلك
وياه راح اقتل قوله شخصيات وهميه الغول
والعنقاء والخل الوفي الغول شخصيه تخرع
واحد طويل عريض ما ادري شلون صاير
والعنقاء طير عنده راس جسمه عود
قالوا له ترى ثالث المستحيلات هذا ما راح
تلقاه
فكل هالقصص ما انتهت عند العرب الاوائل
حتى احنا تاريخنا الحديث يعني
اذا بيخرعون الطفل يقولون له لا تطلع
بالشارع لا تطلع بالفريج ما يسمع الكلام
راح اقول له يا طفل او يا طفله اسمحوا لي
بنات اذا طلعتي القايله بالحر
راح تصادفين حيوان اسمه حماره القايله
وحده راسها راس حمار وجسمها جسم الانسان
والله
لتوصيل رساله انه ترى الخروج القايله ممكن
يضر نفس الشيء واحده تمشي عندها سعف وليف
تقلبون في حزات غير مناسبه
كل هالامثله
كانت جزء من تاريخنا
نفس الوقت لا زال عندنا ضعف في القراءه ما
نكره مشاكلنا عالقه بس احنا اليوم انا
اعتقد انه امام فرصه تاريخيه
فرصه نقدر نرجع فيها لتراثنا
ناخذ هذه القاعده
الكلاميه للكلام المتناقل المتواتر
ونستفيد منها نعالج مشاكلنا احنا اليوم
امامنا شيء اسمه بودكاست واحد يشغل مايك
وناقش وسولف ويتكلم عن قضايا يحللها
يفككها يعالجها وبضر يعالجها بس اهم شيء
انه يناقشها يسولف فيها هذه دعوه الى
النقاش الى الكلام احنا شعوبنا كلها تسمع
وتسمع زين تسمع سياسيين تسمع مثقفين تسمع
رياضيين بس ما تكره
الفرصه التاريخيه هذه اليوم لازم نقتنصها
التاريخ ما يوقف ما يعطينا الفرص ويقول
هاكم الفرصه الواجب علينا احنا نروح
للفرصه وناخذها
القصد من كل هالكلام
احياء
تاريخنا الكلامي المتواتر وتوظيفه في فرصه
للتقدم قد نستفيد منها ونحاول نعالج بعض
مشاكلنا العالقه واللي ما لقينا لها حلول
انا شاكر جدا لحضوركم واسف على الاطاله
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]